[Musique]
non
sur une île isolée à trois heures de
route de la capitale le camp mail est
littéralement classe bouffe
durant l'année scolaire 1600 élèves de
12 ans vient d'y passer une semaine à
découvrir d'où proviennent leurs
aliments
ce matin on fait connaissance avec une
poulette brute certains élèves craignent
de voir mourir un animal mais nous leur
montrons que la viande vient des animaux
et qu'on leur bois de respect et un bon
traitement
sané vinther dirige la fondation à
l'origine du cac parrainé par la grande
coopérative laitière atla
faux la fondation arlanc travail auprès
des adolescents pour améliorer leur
alimentation et leur mode de vie
c'est pour ça qu'on les entraîne en
cuisine à faire les repas eux mêmes ils
vont cueillir des herbes au jardin ou
encore à créer un poisson de cette façon
ils apprendront à cuisiner et à mieux
s'alimenter en ayant préparé les repas
eux mêmes on leur apprend à choisir eux
mêmes les modes de cuisson les
assaisonnements la présentation et de
quelle façon combinée les saveurs
primaire le chou et ta mère et le poulet
c'est même je devrais ajouter des
aliments qui apportent de l'aigre du
salé et sucré
je n'ai qu'à trouver de tels ingrédients
et je réécris un nouveau clairement ils
ne suivent aucune recette il est vrai
ils se sont réparti les tâches puis de
chantier commence et les arômes se
développe dans la grande cuisine
durant la semaine
ils apprennent à faire de la sauce
tomate pour les pâtes fraîches des
gâteaux à partir de farine entière et 2
et des petits déjeuners nourrissant avec
du boeuf il après tu les restes un salad
terrine ou potache et ils planifient les
menus des trois repas qui se doivent de
préparer ensemble de bons repas pour
tous les autres
car si j'échoue personnes ne mangent il
découvre ainsi comment travailler en
commun tout en se respectant entre eux
[Musique]
certains sont chargés de garnir la table
d'autres préparent la pâte appel pour le
petit déjeuner du lendemain ou encore
une crème glacée aux fruits pour ce soir
[Musique]
trois heures après les adieux à la poule
on l'honore par un grand diffèrent
chacun présente sa création
roulades aux tomates séchées pilon
épices et salades et le vol au vent
nationale dans une béchamel au fromage
avec petits pois frais tda 6 mai au bal
accro à la cocaïne au monde offre un tel
cas elle me dit chavanel madame anne
soleil et maquillage
c'est vrai ça les one thing in type iia
ça va nous payer les frais de vente clé
où j'ai demandé à la directrice qu'elle
était la chose la plus importante que le
camp enseigne aux jeunes comme the dance
wii la confiance nous leur faisons
prendre conscience qu'ils peuvent gérer
une cuisine et faire des repas délicieux
de cette façon ils auront davantage
tendance à cuisiner quand ils seront de
retour à la maison la plus grande fierté
c'est de voir des jeunes s'impliquer en
cuisine des jeunes curieux enthousiastes
courageux goûtant des ingrédients
inconnu
je suis persuadé que ce que nous faisons
ici
rené pas que certains sur leur qualité
vie
[Musique]